my name is Amanda Ryman and I'm the
Marijuana Policy Manager for the drug
policy Alliance one of the things we've
seen in several studies are one that
just came out recently is that when a
state passes a medical marijuana law we
don't see an increase in to you even
though medical marijuana is being
normalized and you know many pace across
the country discussions of marijuana use
are definitely down from reefer madness
and more into a therapeutic agent and
mild intoxicant we aren't seeing that
uptick in youth and I think the
normalization what it really will end up
doing which is a good thing it is going
to open up conversations between kids
and their parents about marijuana use in
this country we've been extremely
successful at reducing teen smoking
rates we've youth education we've used
information we do taxes and other types
of restrictions on access and we've been
very successful I think that that shows
it is possible to have a regulated
product that we still believe young
people shouldnt access and that we can
effectively prevent that access
we do not have a breathalyzer for
marijuana the way we do for alcohol but
I think one challenge is you know really
developing the technology around the
driving issue that's something that's
coming it's not here yet but we haven't
really seen a huge disastrous impact on
the roadways to where we feel that this
should prohibit states are moving
forward with legalization